der markusplatz im herzen von venedig
heute nur ein paar vereinzelte touristen
sind unterwegs
und so sieht es hier normalerweise
mitten in der karnevalszeit aus und das
seit jahrhunderten venedigs karneval
zählt zu den ältesten und berühmtesten
der welt in diesem jahr aber
schutzmasken stadt karnevalsmasken die
stadt hat angst sowie das ganze land
italien ist der größte herpesvirus in
europa die aktuellen fälle wurden in den
nördlichen regionen lombardei und
venetien gemeldet von hier stammen auch
die todesopfer seit mittwoch breitet
sich die lungenkrankheit unglaublich
schnell aus und keiner weiß warum so
plötzlich manche orte sind komplett
abgeriegelt das öffentliche leben liegt
weitgehend lahm
fußballspiele der ersten liga werden
abgesagt auch in den nachbarländern hat
man angst christ und heitz minister
sparen sieht in deutschland eine neue
lage die krone epidemie ist als epidemie
in europa angekommen und deshalb müssen
wir damit rechnen dass sie sich auch in
deutschland ausbreiten kann
aber wie gefährlich ist die situation in
deutschland wirklich professor melanie
brinkmann ist biologin am
helmholtz-zentrum sie rät zur
wachsamkeit und empfiehlt dass man ganz
wichtig hygiene maßnahmen trifft und
sich auch überlegt wie kann ich mich im
häuslichen umfeld wirklich schützen
wie kann ich meine familie schützen wie
können wir aufeinander aufpassen zum
beispiel müssen wir jetzt wirklich auf
ältere menschen die ja eine risikogruppe
darstellen besonders schützen und wie
konkret schütze ich meine angehörigen
ich wasche mir die hände wenn ich sie
besuche und berühre erst dann
oberflächen in der wohnung denn wir
wissen ja oder vermuten mit ziemlicher
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich dieses
virus über tröpfchen und
schmierinfektionen weiter verbreitet
eine normale grippe sei viel
gefährlicher als das cola virus heißt es
immer aber warum ergreift italien solch
drastische maßnahmen dieses neuartige
corona virus ist wie der name schon sagt
wirklich etwas ganz neues also unser
immunsystem hat dieses virus noch nie
gesehen ist nicht darauf vorbereitet und
das ist der große unterschied zur
saisonalen grippe hier kennt unser
immunsystem das virus schon zumindest in
einer gewissen form und hat man hat eine
gewisse teilimmunität also diese
drastischen maßnahmen sind denke ich
dadurch begründet dass wir uns vor einem
neuen gegner schützen müssen und seine
ausbreitung so gut es geht reduzieren
und verlangsamen müssen auch weltweit
nehmen die korona fälle zu vor allem im
iran und in südkorea nicht enden
wollende schlangen vor geschäften die
schutzmasken verkaufen von einer
weltweiten pandemie will die
weltgesundheitsorganisation aber noch
nicht sprechen